kommandoübergabe am dienstag bei der
sechsten gebirgs brigade in tirol der
neue kommandant ist brigadier gerhard
treffer
zum neuen komponenten der sechsten
gebirgs pro jahr und es ist auch gut
dass wir einen brigade komponenten hier
an der spitze haben dass sich im gebirge
auskennt und auf den man sich verlassen
kann und das nicht nur wegen seiner
vielseitigen erfahrungen im gebirge dazu
ist neben der körperlichen fitness auch
eine große willensstärke gefragt
ziel in unserer primus ist daher seien
viele derartige menschen mit diesen
eigenschaften zu finden und für unseren
beruf zu begeistern
das gilt gleichsam für frauen und männer
der neue kommandant kann auf einen
breiten erfahrungsschatz zurückgreifen
er ist ausgebildeter jäger offizier
teresa alpinist rs skilehrer abc abwehr
offizier informations offizier und
zuletzt meyer stellvertretender
militärkommandant in tirol ich glaube
alle voraussetzungen die für einen
kommandanten wichtig sind und jetzt ist
es soweit sie werden das kommando die
verantwortung über fünf millionen über
mehr als 2000 soldatinnen soldaten und
zivilbedienstete übernehmen ich bin
überzeugt davon hat er sie werden das
große wissen dass sie haben einsätzen
bei dieser führung der sechster gebirgs
brigade dieses mit unglaublich großer
umsicht mit engagement tun und ich
wünsche ihnen für ihre neue aufgabe
alles erdenklich gute